[Musique]
la bretagne intérieure où je vous emmène
aujourd'hui c'est celle qui est restée
le plus fidèle à ses traditions et parmi
ces traditions l'une des plus solides et
sans doute celle de la galette
la vraie galette fait avec le blé noir
que l'on cultivait et que l'on écrasé
autrefois dans toute la région à saint
jouan de lille par exemple aux confins
de l'île et vilaine et des côtes du nord
où nous avons découvert l'un des
derniers moulins à eau qui fonctionne
encore dans la région aujourd'hui la
farine de blé noir est importé de
turquie principalement mais tous les
boulangers comme monsieur guy mer par
exemple celui de saint jouan de lille
continue d'en vendre ce qu'ils meurent
est ce qu'on peut dire que ça joue en 10
c'est la capitale de la galette pour la
capitale mais on se figure c'est on est
située entre 20 mi chemin entre rennes
et saint brieuc
pour céléber de la rance ça a été
chantée d'abord le flot de baignoires
vous la connaissez sans doute et will
young hôtel est avant tout un outil pour
tout fan et le baignoire c'est justement
s'y faire à faire les galettes et oui et
bien seulement il faut du biennois
bouffer la grève de la grette de
sarrasin ce qu'on appelle nous la vraie
galette dans notre coin qui fait avec du
sarrasin grain de blé noir c'est qu'il
faut pas confondre avec la crêpe
c'est pas du tout la même chose pour
nous affinons et puis après tout moi
c'est pour la même chose non plus à
quelle est la différence on va rappeler
pour ceux qui vont prendre ton la
galette c'est le buzz oui et l'autre sur
la farine de froment avec des yeux et du
sud
mais la farine de sarrasin est là
graines de sarrasin du moins si avec
benoît ramade m²
vous êtes de ces jeunes bretonnes qui
ont gardé la tradition de la galette
vous en faites souvent vous tous les
vendredis
ah bon oui pourquoi le vendredi
manille ce tout le temps fait ça comme
ça mais pourquoi le vendredi parce que
dans le temps là le vendredi c'était
jeunes moi j'ai de la galette
moi j'ai pas devient on a toujours
continué ça finit la semaine
ah bon et vous posiez tout l'europe vous
faites tout le report avec ne leur est
pas avec la galette corps l'olivier ou
soir la mi 2010 parce qu'elle soir c'est
un peu lourd quand même pour l'estomac
alors imaginons qu on est vendredi oui
vous préparez la galette pour la vie de
famille
oui allez vous avez réuni là donc tout
ce qu'il faut pour nous enfants la main
alors on va détailler d'abord provient
vous avez de farine 1 kg de farine de
blé noir ou de sarrasin comme vous
voulez j'ai la même chose
oui un kilo donc de farine de benoist
oui
après il faut quoi alors une petite
poignée de gros sel c'est à dire à peu
près environ 70 grammes et un oeuf
entier
oui et alors de l'eau 2 litres et demi à
peu près selon comme la pâte épaisse ou
non d'accord et vous allez voir combien
de crêpes avec ceux de 36 à 40 selon
l'épaisseur selon comment la russie
augmenterait préparation de la pop que
vous faites
je mets tout mon kilos d'or dans fait
tout doux oui mais je fais un petit cru
comme ça je m'élançais vous faites là
voilà vous êtes très bien au sein de
pala aux caisses le loeuff nous avons
creux oui tu vois là alors après on tour
oui et on commence à mettre l'eau un
tout petit peu faut pas faire de
grumeaux surtout que sinon c'est pas bon
voulez que je vous ai de verser ça va
pour l'ombre
il faut que ça prenne tout doucement
surtout les grumeaux qui ne faut pas
faire combien de temps ça tourne à peu
près pourquoi apple au moins deux trois
ou quatre minutes peut-être cinq ça
dépend voilà je donnais wyss avait plus
commode parce que la pâte commence
oui ça devient du et c'est difficile il
faut mettre juste l'eau qu'il faut aussi
parce que sinon s'il ya un tout petit
peu plus d'eau n ai pas réussi et on ne
peut pas là toute la sphère sur les
galactiques la pâte bien compact oui il
vaut mieux la faire plus épaisse que
tran liquide
il faut que ça prenne tout du ciment sur
la forme était beaucoup plus de wii dès
les yers mais oui c'est pas grave lui
parce qu'il faut tout de même que la
pâte soit suffisamment liquide pour la
verser ensuite investi
ça fait à peu près encore une goutte et
puis ça ira voilà alors elle va reposer
le temps que mon chauffeur de galtier
oui et puis c'est pas parce qu'il m'a
donc on va se reposer quoi cinq minutes
oui non c'est pas nécessaire alors les
bonnes la wii là elle est bonne à
l'ailier elle et quand il est comme ça
c'est impeccable et il faut l'abattre un
petit peu à bon chat bon rat une
omelette très bientôt
alors maintenant que la pâte est prêt
tout qu'est ce que vous faites
alors là je vais préparer la grèce pour
étaler la galette pour progresser le
galtier voilà un jeu mais un jaune
d'oeuf voyez un russe un petit peu de
[ __ ] sindou pour lui le saindoux
c'est la tradition il faut du saindoux
parce qu'on pourrait prendre de l'huile
ou non c'est pas la même chose il faut
du sein de fou
sinon c'est pas une galette bretonne
n'est pas la galette bretonne bon là
vous mélangez alors je mélange c'est
pour que ne que ça n'attache pas
beaucoup mais de l'oeuvre du languedoc
ça empêche attacher ses meilleurs arrêts
oui il faut des simples voilà et puis
quand je veux faire ma galette je vais
mettre un petit peu de cendre au-dessus
comme ça et je vais étaler à chaque fois
que je vais faire une galette
voilà on va vous regarder faire oui
alors voilà le levier d'un quartier
alors cela pose pour allumer l'appareil
de gaz oui avec la bouteille or voilà
voilà puis je repose et ça va chauffer
combien d'or 3 4 minutes quelqu'un qui
veut faire la galette pour soi peut très
bien acheter une petite galtier et puis
s'en servir sur le gaz ah bon c'est une
galette en route
oui c'est impeccable c'est de la fonte
il faut ça parce que c'est toi
l'ordinaire non c'est bon pour la crêpe
mais pas pour la galette ird attaque
maintenant la cuisson des galettes
oui qu'est-ce qu'on fait alors alors en
grèce d'abord pour que ça n'attache pas
voilà ça fume tu peux c'est pour ça que
la cheminée est nécessaire ou alors une
haute et on met en métal de télé avec
quoi me c'est un pirate loire
on tourne à porto voilà faut avoir un
petit coup de main c'est plus facile
pour les écuries combien de temps sur la
plaque alors à peu près 30 secondes sur
chaque côté selon comme les gens aiment
et puis un petit peu plus selon là selon
le goût on va la retourner avec avec la
tournelle la tourbe et on va passer la
tournette il faut qu'elle soit un peu
roots comme ça oui c'est meilleur elle
est plus cuite
c'est aussi bien enfin selon le goût de
chacun
oui si un à qui la veulent plus car elle
est plus cuite
plus digeste les meilleurs face et
chacun ses goûts voilà vous déposez
s'assure une sorte de clé kettering je
sais pas non exactement eh bien vous
garez on va manger là la galette en
famille oui comme si on était vendredi
pareil avec vos parents et plus ils
continuent alors alors 20 km
à pékin la galette avec le lait ribot ah
oui parce qu'il ya plusieurs façons de
la manger la galette avec politique et
que chacun peut à ses préférences
oui voilà ses goûts alors vous attendez
alors monsieur comment vous faites vous
mettez à la galerie révol la galette
inquiète matière et fijm était avec moi
dessus
qu'est ce que vous appelez les rib ou le
lait ribot c'est le résultat
quand on a pas rater quand on l'a fait
peur c'est le lag leur histoire du lait
qui est maintenant la baratte ce qu'on
appelle les battues ou s'il avait battu
aussi oui chez moi dans le nord d'idleb
a tué sa fille si on aime ça les mecs
mais si c'est le lait ribot et alors
c'est vous c'est comme ça que vous
traversiez l'ensemble seniors avec one
way ne servant pas sa soupe qui ont vu
ces d'entrée alors la fin on peut manger
avec les coaches aux pas avec 1,9 et un
buffon bas âge et une fromagerie du
jambon formidable et vous mettez pas de
secret l'annoncé naturel comme ça tout
le monde n'aime pas oui c'est un petit
peu un gros nom assez un petit bout
d'exemple un peu le but de gameiro c'est
spécial je mange mal est avec du beurre
et puis 1,9 que je suis pas mal tiré
pris un bon oui lors comment vous faites
alors
la relève à la bure et à la con comme ça
coince à 9
on ne peut pas merci un petit peu de
beurre sur l'offre quand même pour le
capot et oui
ouais ouais mais je suis tout melton
jamie oliver saleh oui je sais vous avez
eu beaucoup d'enfants
il faut bien aux enfants quand vous
posez des galettes alors chacun avait
ausii sont fabriqués en france
oui enfin c'était surtout à ce moment le
petit écoute il y avait autant de
recettes comme maintenant on y mange
comme ça vous beaucoup avec le bain à
remous et l'offre monsieur yann david
mon mari aime bien ça mais moi l'été
indien du film there j'aime bien
utiliser en plus
surtout quand tout le monde perd ici
aiment bien les galettes
ah ouais faut faire comme sahbi après
les cartels et fois dans la manche avec
de la saucisse avec du avant moi mais un
des producteurs m'ont oignons dans votre
assiette
oui oui vous mélangez oui la très jolie
et ouais
et puis alors puis leur cuisson le
suisse à celui-là d'un tiers se régale
tiers des pendant ce temps la botte la
pousse elle le beurre la galette magal
est alors pour moi comment vous allez
d'après par emma d'arrêt complet oui on
va vous mettre à neuf
d'abord du jeu relève une tranche de
jambon et b du gruyère
c'est ce qu'on appelle la complète sa
complète c'est le bouquet final voilà
maintenant ça
alors alors un petit peu de beurre tout
de même avant je veux un petit peu de
vert way of life
avez vous la préparez sur la canebière
c'est là que ça se passe
le cuit sur la sur la gueule la galette
grand chose oui il faut laisser si
possible en pied la tranche de jambon
sur love est un petit peu de gruyère et
vous repliez les deux bords de la crêpe
de la galette pas confondre sachot c'est
un plat complet c'est complet superbe
résistance
oui voilà alors voilà je suis là que
vous
[Rires]
[Musique]